jennifer walters est une avocate qui a
accidentellement pris le sang de hulk
et est devenue comme un trou de poussin
une hulk exactement
[Musique]
qui sonne bien ce nom
vaut mieux ne pas coller
il y a quelque chose de si surréaliste et si
drôle à propos d'un géant  six pieds sept hulk
dans la salle d'audience,
il s'agissait de mettre un véritable être humain
dans ces situations absurdes,
c'est aussi cool et énervé que nous
pouvons nous en sortir avec une fille, ton cul a l'air
fou en ce moment,
c'est quelque chose que tu penses savoir,
ce qui est la loi montre
et quelque chose que vous pensez savoir
qui est des spectacles de merveilles écraser ensemble
ce spectacle est tellement amusant tout a cette
chose autoréférentielle
ironique qui se passe dans les bandes dessinées elle a brisé
le quatrième mur et était super méta
je veux juste  pour s'assurer que vous ne
pensez pas que c'est l'un de ces camées chaque
semaine, sauf
Bruce et Blonsky
[Applaudissements]
elle a passé tout ce temps à devenir
avocate et cette idée d'être un
super
-héros n'est pas attrayante  pour elle,
être un super-héros est un procès par le feu
oh je ne suis pas un super-héros je veux juste être
un avocat anonyme normal il n'y a
pas de retour à ce que tu étais avant
qui va protéger le monde
sinon des gens comme toi
ça se développe  la définition de ce
que peut être une production de Marvel Studios
c'est une émission révolutionnaire radicale pouvons-
nous prendre des photos s'il vous plaît c'est une
urgence
vous